together
[Music]
hey guys it's Justine and today I have
an unboxing or unbagging if you will of
something that I am so excited about
these are the official iJustine pink USB
cables and we have them in a variety of
sizes a variety of types we've also got
Thunderbolt USBC we've got USB a we even
have USB micro which was a choice that I
made to make even though I wish that it
would go away forever but if we have to
still have it let's make it Pink so all
of these cables I partnered with Condor
blue on and they are an incredible
camera company that makes so many
amazing camera accessories cables and
now Condor blue I guess we could call
them Condor pink in the meantime what's
really great about partnering with
Condor blue is not only do they have
high quality products but they do have a
lifetime warranty on all of their cables
and that's one thing that has been
upsetting about other cable companies is
most of them barely have a warranty at
all so the fact that these are backed by
a lifetime warranty is super exciting so
here's everything thing that we have in
front of us we've got super cool
packaging and another really exciting
thing is of course yes we do have all of
the cables but we've also got an
official iJustine carrying pouch this is
actually fully custom designed this was
inspired by this really cheap mesh bag
that I had been using for the past
couple of years and I liked it but there
were so many things that I I didn't like
about it the only thing that I really
liked about it was the fact that it was
mesh and it was about this size so this
has a super high quality industrial
zipper with these metal iJustine pull
tags that match the pink metal on the
USB cables the mesh is also a larger
more industrial mesh
and one of the best parts about it is
the inside has two little Loops so if
you have an apple pencil or even a
analog pencil to to write like the the
to write on paper or a marker or
something like that you can put that
right inside there this also Zips all
the way open and I've been traveling
with this for the past couple of weeks
and it is so perfect so I'm so happy
with how this came out so let's unbag
all of these cables and I'll show you
what we've got now obviously since I am
a huge iPhone fan we had to make some
lightning cables now originally my plan
was we weren't gonna make these because
I thought that the new iPhone would be
USBC but spoiler alert
um it's not it's still lightning and I
feel like a lot of people have iPhones
or other products that are lightning
enabled so we've got a USB a and the
USBC so whichever one you decide that
you need now these are actually as you
can tell in this nice little box
packaging that's because these are
certified to work with Apple products
now let's open these up this is the
USB a
I like that these have these little
reinforcements for the cable and the USB
meets because it helps it become way
more sturdy now this is a braided cable
it is beautiful it is pink oh my gosh I
love it so much and you'll see right
here it's got my little name on it
and we just take a look at these zippers
like look how beautiful they are I've
also got our little name there we've got
Condor blue and I just seen on the seam
it's like my favorite thing ever our
next cable we have the C2 lightning I
mean I think we've all seen this before
each of these cables are 3.3 feet which
I felt was long enough but not too short
but also not too short so it's kind of
just right there perfectly in the middle
the next one we have a six foot USBC and
this one has a right angle USBC on it
this actually comes in a one foot three
feet and six feet version this can
deliver up to 100 watts of power and it
has fast data transfer speeds up to 10
gigabytes a second here's the one foot
version
and the three feet
I do realize that some people don't
always use USBC to USBC so we also have
got the usb-a to USBC and this one is
three feet long
there it is this will give you up to 60
watts of power and you can get fast
transfer speeds at five gigabytes a
second so depending upon what speeds
you're looking for you can choose a
cable that is right for you speaking of
speed there is a need for it and we also
have a thunderbolt 4 cable this could
quite possibly be my favorite most of
the drives that I have are Thunderbolt
compatible so this one is definitely at
the top of my list this comes in a three
foot length and for a thunderbolt cable
I feel like that's pretty standard this
is able to power 8K display or dual 4K
displays this has some very fast data
transfer speeds up to 400 gigabytes a
second of course we've got our iJustine
logo on the other side now the last but
not least is the micro USB cables
this is a 10 inch cable and this is
great for a lot of tiny accessories
drones batteries cameras headphones you
name it mostly I use this to charge my
wireless lavalier microphones so this is
definitely something that I really
wanted was a small micro USB cable
because all of the ones that I have are
so long that it's like I don't need that
I just need something tiny and small to
be able to charge now this one is 30
inches which it is a little bit larger
so this is I feel like a standard size
which I also like because sometimes you
do need to plug things into the wall so
you do need a little bit longer of a
cable so both of these together it's
like a dream come true let's make it
smile it's smiling this is the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen I
actually haven't seen them all inside of
this case this is the first time look at
this it looks so great
I love it so here they are I'm gonna put
a link in the description if you want to
purchase these and Condor blue actually
has a huge giveaway happening on their
website so I'll put a link in the
description if you want to check that
out and enter they're not only doing a
giveaway of all of the iJustine cables
they're also giving away a ton of condor
blue accessories and goodies and even a
camera so go check it out Link in the
description on how to enter and also how
to purchase these I look forward to you
guys getting these in your hand and
actually seeing how amazing they are I'm
such a huge fan of all of their cables
so I could not believe that these are
officially iJustine cables and they're
pink and they're beautiful
oh I love it so much oops I found a
couple more cables that didn't make the
cut get in
I cannot wait to see them out in the
wild on your gear in your hands char
ging all of your devices even if you
aren't a fan of the color pink the color
pink is such a great accent to anything
and I feel like a lot of times in the
tech industry everything is very dark
colored or you have a bunch of basic
white cables and these will definitely
spice up your set your desk your
charging situation and I also feel like
it's a pretty good conversation starter
also it doesn't make a bad gift again
link is in the description and I can't
wait for your devices to I was gonna say
get their hands on them but they don't
most devices don't have hands you know
what I mean
foreign